clear first i can tell you that i've
seen sam in the gym at the hotel so he
knows about needing stamina for this sam
you've had an incredible tournament you
lost a big game and came back storm back
to have this result
this final game however we're wondering
what were you thinking about going into
the game given that you have two players
in
in seoul and fabiano caruana who if they
win your title chances are over
uh well first of all before the
tournament my plan was to play very
solid with black and i didn't really
want to make an adjustment for the last
round specifically
i've even against john burke i played my
lines in italian it was an interesting
game back and forth
and daniel's been playing very
enterprising openings in pretty much
every game so i definitely didn't expect
this to happen but okay
so you wanted to have a fighting
position but it all depended on him
having the white pieces how he wanted to
play i mean if he played like d3c
through i think we'd have a long
interesting game
so now you're
uh at you're in clear first however it
is guaranteed somebody's going to tie
you because of that so robson game
your thoughts going into the fact that
you might not only be in a two-way tie
it could be a five-way tie at this time
oh yeah i mean
crazy things could happen today and well
obviously i'm hoping that the two
leaders i'm tied with don't win
and it really doesn't matter if it's a
two-way tie or 10-way time but at the
end of the day i just want to be in the
playoffs all right there won't be a
10-way target thank goodness the
commentators would leave the building
your thoughts on who's playing the best
right now you see fabi storming the way
he is and wesley who has missed the real
chance to already secure the
championship do you think there's some
good chances who do you think is have a
better chance of coming out of this
today
um well fabi's definitely after the game
against me has been playing really well
three and a half out of four he'll
definitely put some pressure today with
white
and wesley um i think the thing about
wesley is if ray really tries to win
with black he'll definitely get chances
too
so you're looking at that all right well
you're going to be a spectator like the
rest of us go get your arrest hit that
gym to get the stamina up and we'll see
you hopefully in the playoffs thank you
sam regardless of what happens today our
congratulations seriously really really
great tournament keep it up thank you
all right good luck sam
nice to be clear first